but there was some research done by a
creator that discovered seven niches
that make the most money and here they
are Health business investing auto
reviews real estate insurance and online
marketing and this data was collected by
studying cpms in different niches across
Russia the U.S Canada the UK Germany
Australia and India so global
deep dive study what are the highest
cpms health business investing auto
reviews real estate insurance and online
marketing so what are the most
profitable topics on YouTube now if you
were trying to financially position your
channel to have the greatest Advantage
it would be smart to pick a high-paying
industry not just for CPM perhaps but
because of brand deal sponsorships and
other opportunities it doesn't mean
however though that you'd have to be in
one of those seven I think you
understand that but it could also speak
to the financial upside or lack of
upside at least in terms of how much
you're going to make from ad Revenue so
one of the questions that you should be
thinking is how much is how much are
businesses willing to pay to advertise
to this demographic if you think about
it if it's auto reviews someone's
actually going to buy a car and if it
was a loan product of some kind perhaps
or if it was Insurance of of something
like that like these that'd be a
lucrative audience to advertise in front
of it might be harder to sell Auto
Insurance on a Minecraft playthrough
video so again that's the thinking we
want to develop